joseph et tom greeter ce terme qui vient
de l'anglais to greet accueillir désigne
un habitant qui fait visiter
bénévolement sa ville par
l'intermédiaire de l'office de tourisme
et mardi matin ce retraité du milieu
industriel était attendu par un couple
d'anglais et leurs amis versaillaise au
coeur
joseph fait partie du réseau de greeters
de la cité royale un réseau qui vient de
s'agrandir avec un cinquième bénévoles
recrutés et qui attire de plus en plus
de touristes il ya un boom as par
rapport à l'année dernière là j'ai une
demande pour pour une
mamie et ses petits enfants qui veulent
découvrir versailles autrement avec des
anecdotes
voilà surtout des coupes des étrangers
pas mal et des français aussi joseph
même son petit groupe au marché notre
dame par la rue des deux portes
l'occasion de glisser une nouvelle
anecdote
quand on traversait à l'époque
il fallait faire attention aux habitants
qui jeter leurs ordures par les fenêtres
l'ambiance de la balade et décontracté
comme le veut la philosophie du concept
basé sur les changes amical plus que sur
des connaissances encyclopédiques
j'ai beaucoup d'amis que ça soit aux
états unis en angleterre en italie en
egypte en israël au brésil
et moi quand je vais chez eux ils ne
font visiter et moi quand ils viennent
ici je leur fait visiter ma vie au les
châteaux pas question pour autant de
concurrencer les guides conférenciers
une charte précise l'activité du greeter
aucune rétribution financière ni pour
boire pas de visite avec un axe
patrimoniale le phénomène mondial des
greeter né aux états unis il ya près de
20 ans ont créé à paris lyon nantes et
versailles depuis 2010 il n'a pas encore
séduit l'office de tourisme de saint
quentin en yvelines pour découvrir
versailles il est indispensable de
remplir un questionnaire les visites
étant programmée selon les
disponibilités des greeters